昨天晚上美股其實很熱鬧
那只創高了費半大漲4%以上
我們看到Meta Intel MD
各個去往上急噴
那當然這樣的行情很誘人
在台股的話
一定是中小型股
才會有這樣的一個活潑度
不過這邊就要請教志願哥了
因為今天創高
雖然中小型股我們都知道更飆
可是你看剛剛像明漢也講了
如果你現在才要介入
可能你買大型全資股
你壓力沒那麼大
但是又很羨慕中小型股在飆
其實用基金更能達到這樣的目的
對 因為現在盤面的節奏
真的變化得非常的快
有時候我們想要去抓
這個盤面的節奏
還是真的不是那麼容易
當然現在
當我們台股還在糾結說
中秋變盤的時候
梅谷給了方向
當然昨天的一個盤面
以前被稱之為
阿斗的Intel
現在不能叫人家阿斗
你看這個線型多強
跳空
當然來講有一個利多
其實這一段時間
我覺得都有利多
包括美國政府的一個介入也好
現在來講的話
他現在還要跟我們的友達
衝進所謂的先進封裝
所以過去被認為是大牛的友達
現在也不得了
今天也是大漲
而且是連續兩天都大漲的一個情況
另外一檔是AMD的一個部分的話
也是這樣的一個狀況
就是說他的一個
今年以來的投資報酬率
非常的高幣
回答還多很多很多
沒錯 180%
那昨天的股價也是在創新高
所以你看其實在
美國的一個盤面上面來講
都有一個很不一樣的一個狀況
那其實台股也是這個樣子
所以我們看到就是說
當然今天最亮眼的部分
就是在創意身上
那創意當然我覺得它有幾個利多
基本面的部分
當然有台積電的這個產能的一個支援
那另外來講
外資Alethia它預估說
創意未來三年的一個獲利
會增加八倍
那載板的部分
之前新興這樣的一個利空
其實沒有把載板的部分
給打下來
那南電其實就在千元的附近
進行震盪
那今天載板三雄也是都非常的強
我們以南電作為例子來講的話
感覺上來講
好像都有在攻的這種意味在
那當然為什麼
台灣這些中小型股
为什么可以特别的飙
比台积电这些
可能大型的全市股
都还要来的飙
我觉得最主要还是来自于
我们基本面的底气非常的好
那当然我们讲到
这个投资价值的话
一般都会先看
本益比的一个部分
那我们看我们台股的本益比
我觉得真的是
还有在上修的空间
我们算便宜的市场
对 真的好便宜
你看以这个深蓝色的
未来12个月的前瞻
本益比来讲的话
就算是在最高点
7月份的时候
6月底7月份的时候
也不过才20多倍
那现在呢
大概在19倍上下
那如果你是以未来24个月
就未来两年的前三本益比来看的话
它更只有多少
不到15倍
你可能会觉得说
为什么未来两年反而更低
对啊 越涨越便宜
对 就是因为我们获利变得又更好了
所以右边这张你可以看到
就是说台湾上市柜的
这个EPS的成长的一个水位来讲
紅色的部分是2027年
你看它成長的抖度非常的高
相較於2025年
比較平緩的一個狀況來講的話
增加很多
所以預估在今年
它的年增長率的部分
就大概四成以上
明年更高 到五成以上
所以你換算下來的話
可能真的是越漲
反而是越便宜的一個狀況我們的評價超合理對 台股為什麼這麼強我告诉大家因为快要第三季了我刚好也做一个所谓的一个统计的部分台股今年的涨幅
差不多是60%
很强对不对
对
告诉大家
这个涨幅刚好跟肺半
还有韩国的部分平起平坐
那为什么可以这么强
就是因为我们在基本面的部分
真的是非常的强
那过去可能我们都会讲说
我们重在所谓的AI半导体
但现在是一个全面的扩散
扩散到什么
AI的基建
五层蛋糕
黄人群奖的
还有包括我们有最完整的
AI的一个供应链
所以我们在社会的族群的部分
譬如说像GPU的算力增加的话
会好到什么
PCB跟CCL
那功耗大幅的成长的话
就会好到所谓的
电源供应的一个部分
那AI的晶片设计越来越复杂
所以半导体测试的部分
也是非常非常的强
那其他部分包括像ABF载版
还有已经涨过好几轮的记忆体
这些都是非常强的一个族群
那这边呢
再比较细的跟大家讲一下
就是说AI带动的层面呢
对我们台股来讲是非常的多
从上游的部分你可以看到
包括像IC设计的部分
还有包括刚刚明昙也提到的
半导体测试的
还有我们刚刚讲记忆体的部分
那更好的部分呢
其实在这些所谓的关键零组件上面
因为关键零组件呢
它基本上来讲
它獲利一個成長的幅度又更高
所以像最近盤面的一個主流
雖然變化得很快
但是都集中在這些族群上面
包括什麼 散熱
散熱今天也是高麗雙紅都漲停
對 窄板的部分
三雄都漲停
那前一波的光
雖然今天光沒有什麼表現
但是光其實都還一直都滿亮的
那電源供應器的部分
其實在從去年延伸到現在
也都沒有太大的一個改變
那其他的部分
我們如果以光收發模組來看的話
其實高盛之前就有出一個報告
是不斷看好今年跟明年
因為包括800G跟1.6T的光收發模組的部分
都是會不斷的一個成長
雖然FCC有一個雜音
但是其實好像也沒有發生太大的一個改變
講這個CCL可能因為CPU普及
就用不到那麼高規格
但幾天內就已經沒有人在聊了
好 那接下來可能你會講到就是說
如果我要捕捉
刚刚讲的那些个股
你会发现到就是
盘面的节奏
并不是容易那么掌握
而且有些大部分很贵
对
所以我觉得呢
我们为什么一直强调
就是推荐大家
就是说你比较省心的方式
其实是可以用基金
或ETF的方式来进行布局
是一个比较好的一个状况
那我们我刚刚也提到
就是台股的一个涨幅
现在跟背办韩国是平起平坐
而且台股相关的基金
表现得比指数还要好
基金医师我们讲了很多都是ETF
今天我们回来讲基金
基金的一个表现来讲的话
我刚好做一个统计
就是说台股涨60%
我们台股基金表现怎么样
我们台股基金主要有两类
一个是中小型的
一个是台股基金
中小型基金的话
我算了一下
今年以来的平均是涨了90%
平均吗
平均
平均90%
那么台股基金平均涨多少
是80%
也很厉害
对 所以说如果你平均来讲的话
台股的中小型基金
它的一个表现是比较好的
平均90%
当然了 如果因为有
毕竟有第一名跟最后一名
我们还是要看一下表现比较好的
那今天表现比较好是哪一些呢
是世禄的台湾乐活中小
那还有包括像统一中小
野村中小 第一金小型精选这一些
其中我们看一下
世禄的台湾中小的部分的话它到今年以來的一個投資績效已經多少將近1552%這個真的是非常驚人年初放一筆錢到現在就漲了152%
對 而且以這個績效來講
我們說比平均多了多少
超過60% 非常的多
另外來講台股基金的部分
今年你會發現到
像元大的部分也還蠻多的
過去好像就是野村那些在纏鬥
那今年來講好像是
這個元大的部分也有竄起
但是如果跟斯羅德台灣中小相比的話
好像也有一點落差
因為最高的部分也將近只有
差不多138
也不錯啦 說實話
但是落差大概有十幾個percent以上
那如果跟主動式ETF的比呢
你會發現到981A
是今年以來的冠軍
是78.3
哇 這個差距跟斯羅德台灣
樂火中小有差距更多一點
當然我覺得就是說
因為牌面節奏變化得很快
跟操作邏輯上
也有很大一个区隔
那你可能会很好奇
就是说
一样都是在AI科技
那为什么呢
是若得台湾乐活中小
可以领先这么多这么强
其实呢我告诉大家
就是我有观察到就是
7月份的回档
它有没有回档
它当然有回档
可是我觉得它有一个
比较厉害的地方
在这个地方
6月份是不是台股
涨到相对的一个高点
大家都很high的时候
对
它做了什么
它的现金的一个比重
拉得很高
代表他怎么样
他其实在6月份的时候
是卖很多股票
获利了结
对
那个7月份的时候呢
他的现金水位怎么样
反而变得很低
他在干嘛
7月份的时候减了很多股票
逢低加码
对 所以为什么他在
绩效商朋友做一个很大的落差
其实我们常在讲
有时候我们在看
我们能够看到的
有时候只是这个
他现在包括月报
投资组合的一个部分
那ETF的话
就是每天的一个持股
变化的一个方向
但那些都是靜態的
這個動態的方向
我覺得才是最重要的
你如何能夠買在低點
賣在高點
才是你的一個績效
跟人家有一個比較大
區隔的一個重要的一個關鍵
所以你看他6、7月份這個佈局
我覺得在這個部分來講
也就是他勝出的一個
很重要的一個原因
好 也是我們一般投資人
比較做不到的
6月恨不得all in
7月下得要命
那當然這兩基金來講的話
可能我們過去
大概就最近这半年
提到一个比较多
但是它不是新的基金
它已经成立超过10年以上
超过10年的基金
这个绩效的一个统计
是到8月底为止
你看它10年的绩效到多少
10倍以上
帮大家赚了10倍
真的是非常非常强
所以你会发现到
我们刚才讲的这个
巴菲的滚雪球的效应
你如果找到一个
好的投资标的的话
其实它那个长期的
投资报酬率是非常的高
那今年以来真的已经超过50%
而且我们刚刚讲
9月份的部分是将近152
这个到8月底是150
代表它已经怎么样
更领先创新高
台股今天的一个涨不被没收
但是它已经提前创新高
所以这非常的强
所以这部分来讲
我觉得值得大家再留意一下
那成分股的一个部分
我觉得非常重要
就是说我们刚刚讲是近概的部分
可是呢有比较强的部分
包括他选到创意
南电
选到南电了
但是其实我们刚刚讲
因为这个是上个月的
因为我们看基金的部分
通常是上个月的部分
一个月才看到一次内
对 所以其实它的布局
早就已经并不是在这个时间点
所以我为什么讲说
动态跟静态的部分
我们要拆开来看
它布局在先
它后面享受到的就是一个
资本利得收割的一个效果
就特别的一个强
而且这些个股里面
我看了一下前十党
那除了光宝科是比较便宜的之外其他我觉得都是上千都不是一般散户可以买的所以我觉得就是這些都是好股票但是對散戶朋友來講的話布局有一些些困難所以這個部分
我還是蠻推薦大家去做的
那當然就是說
如果說以這個
所謂的一個配置上面來講的話
穩件型你可以先配置30%
那麼機器型的
你可以把它配置的一個多一點
那另外來講就是說
它本身來講也是TISA級別的
它是TISA級別的
所以如果是小资组的话
我觉得也蛮适合
因为波动大
你可以用这个部分
那斯洛的这个团队的话
我觉得大家也不陌生
因为他们的境外基金很有名
也是我们李伯基金讲的一个常客
可是可能过去大家提
这个台股基金的话
可能没有听到这么多
但实际上他们也生根很久
那我们看到他们的一个全球布局
就他们包括在美洲
或者是欧非中东
甚至于在亚洲
都有一个很坚强的一个
研究团队
所以我觉得以台股研究团队来讲
他们各有一个优势
为什么
他们同时间因为有跨国
他们可以听到亚洲的投资团队
带来的讯息
所以当台 日 韩
这三个国家
比如说日本跟韩国
产业面上面有一些重大变化的时候
他们的台股团队可以优先去吸收
他们在方便
他们在判断上面来讲
会更精准
更不要讲就是说
我们跟废办的连结更强
那如果他们又有美国投资团队的话
那在这方面来讲
我觉得也是非常好的一件事情
那么他们
我刚好就是跟
这个他们投金玉连在聊的时候
刚好也得到一个讯息
就是他们要把
这一个基金的
这个成功的一个范例
互制到他们下一个产品上面
也就是失落的
可能他们下一个产品
会布局到AI相关的
主动式的ETF
那我觉得这个战场
真的是非常好
就是越来越多的一个
好的主动式的ETF来参与这个市场
我觉得我也蛮期待
就是他们推出的这个新产品
好 当然基金的优势
刚刚看了
不用这个每天公布持股
经理人默默低调滑水
很厉害
7月还逢低 超低
而且入门的门槛又很低
对不对
用TESA级别的话
手续费和经理费也可以省下来
对 管理费又更适
可是如果同样发行主动式ETF的好处是
挂在台股的交易市场上面
大家可以每天看
有交易的快乐
入手方便都很棒
各有他们的一个优势
我觉得就是说可以
让投资人有多一个选择
是好 这边非常谢谢基金医生
台股市场
现在看起来是世界第一强
但是基金医生有告诉我们
上半年费半跟韩股比较强
为什么下半年我们比较强
因为我们真的订单满手
成绩很好
明年还会赚更多
所以台股叫做越涨越便宜
但是中小型股
大家要掌握轮动的节奏
真的比较辛苦些
刚介绍的是
施罗德台湾乐活中小基金
哇这个小资足
真的几千块就可以参与了
买了很多都是高价股
不如说不要买零股了
就买基金
比较快能参与到台股的动能上涨
而同步的
他们也即将在11月
有机会推出主动式的ETF
多种选择给大家参考
当然赵海是要提醒
投资ETF投资基金
都是有赚有赔有风险的
申购钱一定要详阅公开说明书
今天非常谢谢三位的朋友来到现场
我们今天参与了台股再度创下历史新高
即使800点的上影线
可能大家觉得心里面有点毛毛的
但是我们不用管什么中秋廉价
我们先看台股
外销订单
业绩的成长
这些都是很强的底气
下次回档的时候
我们一定要把握时机
那也希望今天理财大安秀
对你投资有帮助
明天再会了
拜拜